[Applause]
and here comes powell chance to tie or
take the lead depending on shot
selection
pedal for the lead oh miles
powell murphy picked up by powell shot
clock at five
jumper on the way mcgee there's the
record
fletcher mcgee he wants to play he wants
the ball
the tournament's two leading scorers
at home it's a jaw jam
what a great backdoor cut oh backs it
out
kevin kelly wants it and gets it drawing
to vermont d again
kevin galley
through a house full of catamounts
it's a race
jalen smith a grown man slam
[Applause]
hugh separation three another
[Applause]
butler long pass gillespie left the load
the flush keep going to the hoop
[Applause]
they've got an eight-point lead tying
their biggest tonight down goes cody
martin
ahead it goes hudson will fly and jam
up high down hard
until he cuts oh kelly
bring it on big man and colin gillespie
trucks
samuels jermaine
samuels ole miss has missed his last
move by tyree now they're going to try
to switch pick and roll while they
blitzed it
trice can't turn the corner wide open
is iverson
fish is finished the shot and move on
bro
that's what that's talking
[Applause]
coming with the nastiness officials
didn't see that
this is how you have an exclamation
point
brady asking for it underneath it
and he got it
[Applause]
look at that it's pretty explosive right
there himself gotta watch your head
woods bringing it and lobbing it and
jamming it his job
waters makes his move three seconds
waters to the rim lay up guard
1.6 maryland has no timeouts ayala
three-quarter court
it's over march
equals madness
as bushido is looking for a foul thotson
accelerating the other way for two
and there johnson got bushwhacked oh my
livers oh my goodness skywalking
with the slam with authority especially
for a guy who's a great offensive
rebounder
and here's the break clerk oh
showtime in salt lake phil wants to draw
some contact
there on clark but he says guys first
you got to stay stationary
take the contact
sorry lisa go ahead
mcbringer i'm telling you if minnesota
can just hit a couple
oh he just crowbared one in
lawson's going right to the hoop he
slips a little bit and okiki with the
block
up ahead harper
[Applause]
[Music]
with the left-handed jam and a foul
should have been
under two minutes cook inside oh
[ __ ] william
wasting a lot of time he's gonna end up
sending
williamson driving in on taco
[Applause]
jerome look at the passes he makes so
any hand any tight pass
yes a second brilliant
[Music]
[Applause]
has given tennessee the lead
shot clock down to nine ply can't
dribble himself free
he's gonna have to take a long one climb
step back three for the time
he's done it again got 17 minutes left
[Applause]
you don't have to settle for jump as you
drive and put pressure
on the defense your double bonus
[Applause]
and it's like a heavyweight fight this
was an assistant rick mccarrick of st
louis with the assistant at st
john's and now here at buffalo with the
flush
perkins why not and it's 76-59
auburn north carolina just not getting
into the float
white the speed and slam and a chance at
three
pretty impressive after crashing to the
floor hitting two free throws getting up
and doing that
look at this cyan right over the top
rim how about this big time leave the
chandeliers put the china away with this
guy around the house
okay say that should be outlawed he goes
right over
ty's back
[Applause]
over the top taco underneath
and one wow and tied at the line he's
only a 36
percenter from the line six the largest
lead of the game by virginia technis
jones
[Applause]
how high can you go
put this i thought that was going out of
bounds we're down to 37 seconds to play
davis wants to do it himself pj
washington a big time block
kentucky down by one hero
oh tyler hero her hero
is a machine he sure is and that's a
defensive machine right there
timing that play perfectly and
understanding the scouting report
and look at hiro he couldn't wait and i
mean he couldn't wait for that ball to
get to his fingertips
a big moment and never shoot the gap on
the shooter when you have two screens
coming
he gave back to three he just knocked
out edwards a long range three
nothing but net jerome
short back down the aquitaine a race for
it into the hands of clark
got a chance to win it here up the front
is
[Music]
he sees the time he floats it up over
the outstretched arms of harm
this is what you have to love this is
what the tournament is about
for williamson looked at it officially
thought someone was on him
oh yes
[Applause]
a little more motion running the
baseline here's that little flex and pin
down
a little action brown wants it shoots it
got it
boy i don't know where that's been he
might have been fouled too on that
three-pointer
they don't have a speed guy to go to the
rim
gotta hurry now shot from the corner
goes
down the one with 6.5
for the lead he got all three
budgets on the wings
colbert got the separation step
it up big time dagger now to the star
the big 12
player of the year on the acc's top
defender
in the page puts it up for the lead
unbelievable use of the left hand
got to go fast jerome gives it up
far side
[Applause]
oh my goodness with 12 seconds remaining
they really do they've been able to get
through the cracks too
show zone to get to that man hunter hit
the shot at the end of regulation
does it again rebound into the hands of
hunter
and virginia with the all-time
turnaround title